- So, Margo, can you explain
the story of the movie?
- Well, Barbie Land is perfect,
and the Barbies are having
perfect day after perfect day.
And everything's just
wonderful in Barbie Land,
unless you're a Ken,
or until you have an existential crisis,
which my Barbie does.
- What about the rest of you?
Who's your Barbie?
America, you can say.
- I'm not a Barbie.
I mean, I am a Barbie
'cause we're all Barbies.
Unless you're a Ken,
then you're not a Barbie.
But I'm a human in the movie.
- Because there's Barbie Land.
- There's Barbie Land.
And in the last trailer
you kind of see the hint of Barbie and Ken
are headed toward the real world.
And in the real world
my character, Gloria,
encounters Barbie, and it's a connection.
And hijinks ensue from there.
And I think that's all I'm allowed to say.
(all laughing)
- And then, "I don't
wanna spoil everything."
Who's your Barbie?
Who do you play?
- Did you guys ever have a Barbie,
like the one Barbie that
you designate as like, her,
(audience laughing)
where you cut their hair,
burn their clothes,
- [Kelly] Test everything out.
- And draw on them?
That's the one I play.
Mine were all them.
- Because, let's face it,
we all had one.
- Oh yeah.
- You're like, "What
if I colored her hair?
She needs a haircut."
(all laughing)
I love your Barbie.
Can you do the splits in real life,
or did they have to like-
- I can go to about there,
(all laughing)
and then the whole system breaks down.
I can't do a split.
- Oh my God, way to go!
Then the editing job is incredible.
- Oh no, they did this
whole technical thing
where my legs are always at a 180.